[Music]
hey what's going on everybody at Sean
Evans from first week beef coming at you
from London hot one it's going
international but we have some downtime
and I'm joined by big Lou all right Oh a
burger gang Burger gang or die you
already know what it is and we're here
at Camden Market on the hunt for the
best burger in London thankfully I have
my finest guy on the job Bono's let's do
it it's gonna have a little mooch
[Music]
so this is it mate this is like walking
down Wembley way for the goldmine burger
is all about today is this right here
the cliff it's a 90 day aged beef patty
so they're doing a truck and brisket mix
for their patties their bone marrow in
there this is devised this is what the
crowd came to see but this is like
stand-up you pay cut out your check one
of them one so we need a couple of
Ivoire nothing to just start a ball
rolling yeah double clip so we're going
to double click that's the big man order
I'm a big man so this is definitely a
two-hand situation oh [ __ ] it's kind of
true I feel like I'm neglecting it a
little bit right now like we should
learn let's give it some attention yeah
let's do it
hmm the best kind of burger is a burger
that you bite into and you just F eart
lessly rip through every single layer
the operation that they're doing is
something that's become really popular
in the UK dry-aging beast might look a
bit ropey when you see it hanging in a
fridge it's been there for 60 plus days
a little furry but you know I mean just
work that you carve that [ __ ] off and
it's going to leave the most delicious
tasty beef but literally you were ever
farm Paul kind of get a steak sort of
bite in there you know rich and it's
surrounded in haste that one bite of
this burger you kind of feel like you're
ate a whole steak or something you know
yeah big Lou I'm already impressed
burger and Beyond it stacks up to New
York you have nothing to be ashamed of
but I flew across the Atlantic I want
something that I can't get in New York
okay I want something unique to London
something special okay so this is Roger
or for the big gun I'm going to take you
to Bleecker Street burger and I'm going
to introduce you to a double
cheeseburger
with a layer of delicious British black
pudding all right can't wait let's go
just do it wait this is this is the one
you can surprise this is the crown jewel
the mut nut we really for make this is
the one this is like the mecca for all
broken heads in London this is where you
can to get your feet can i order two of
your finest Bleecker Black Sea but if I
feel like is almost a proposal moment
where I'm getting my offering I'll give
you a lot
all right the immediate thing that's
sticking out to me here and I have the
same thing is it Slayer
you know what I mean it's like the earth
but so this is the moment I should
explain to you what exactly black
Britain is black pudding is pink blood
in fat and oh it's a no-brainer so
Cheers
well initial thought how would you
describe that I mean just weird because
something with so many layers it's still
quite refined in quite delicate and
because of the strike is immune to the
black pudding and put a cheeseburger
it's a whole different category of food
your mouth it's like nothing I've ever
eaten
this is just one of those burgers that
it's just so rich you know what I mean
and then the black pudding the British
is help oh the most British thing that
you've already late it's a sacrilege
embrace breakfast if you're not
incorporating black pudding in that [ __ ]
I'm not interested it's such an obvious
decision to flat be in a burger here's
not say about British burgers in general
the two that you've shown me today okay
messy as hell like this is a wash your
hands on every bite situation in the
United States I know you're talking
about it being the gold standard with
burgers but it's kind of jumped the
shark in a way you know what I mean
they're always stacking it up and but
here you have some real British
restraint the only thing is that black
pudding which if anything kind of
accentuates all the good things about a
classic burger percent because a lot of
people even here other complicating
things you know we've got the whole man
be food generation of people trying to
put savings in versus you know I just
wanna put crazy [ __ ] in there it just
rather belong it is refined this is a
cheeseburger with a price to Britain
just slid in there you know and it's not
for me it's a perfect marriage it's a
perfectly well balanced well ratioed
delicious decadent life of the UK earthy
meaty yet delicious from saying that's
like right back here in London
give me I'd better bring in yeah we will
love out here find a friend that takes
you to find the best burger in the
country that's the shot Evans tip of the
day well front of a vine your natural
rate and your real lambda now you're
cocky rebel
hey what's going on hot ones fans if you
liked the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you liked the video subscribe thank you
very much
I appreciate you I love you more than a
friend